you said earlier when people like Gary
do you think pickleball is a fat I'm
like
everything has to evolved and be
interesting but a few things I've seen
in the last 30 years and I pay a lot of
attention to this capture at the level
of speed that are something that is
humanly true people want to be outside
people want to be in shape people want
to be active people want to be
competitive hilarious I think said or
Drew like people want to be social to
trash talk like there's it's very clear
that this has the ingredients another
bet of why I think this is going to work
is I mean I think there's really the
elements on the two things that matter
right and I think the MBA benefits from
this currently which is strong TV strong
in person I think pickleball has those
elements and that gives it a lot of
upside as a sport